welcome back to turbo dismount girl but
yo get updated so now you can actually
steer it in the game how about that
so my new bestie in the whole world
world wide web asked me if I could play
this with her that's not true but she's
gonna play with me anyway it's Taylor
Swift Taylor I love you Taylor Swift
okay which post shall Taylor Taylor
you're crazy
Taylor no don't please don't do that Tim
right let's do normal tape all right
[ __ ] it Taylor Yolo style let's do it
alright dodge the traffic ahh tail damn
it Taylor is late for the Grammys she
better hurry up Taylor where is she
hey [ __ ] shake it off Taylor hang on
Taylor hang on Taylor Taylor no okay
first of all dodge two pins dodge him
and damn it are you kidding me all good
all is well [ __ ] yeah
alright go Taylor make me proud what are
we going Taylor what are you doing oh
god they see her Taylor Taylor go oh
that burns
that was close one oh my god the cops
are after Taylor you're never gotta be
out i ah oh hey how you doing Adam
cinder and a senator and I'm saying
there and
and Sandler Adam Sandler and I'm saying
dick I love you Adam Sandler okay oh my
god shut up Adam
wherever I go he's looking at me it's so
disturbing what the [ __ ] is all this
oh no way hey which one nice tits at him
I gotta say and him sander it's late for
his next meeting with his aging oh [ __ ]
he had a great ass crack though Adam
don't please don't look at me like that
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine
don't worry look like you'll be fine go
Adam go make me proud don't touch go
Adam go out up what the [ __ ] just
happened where is his head where is his
head there it is
where is he going he's flying so high
I'm going to my people they called me
from a bath what are you doing it don't
worry about me pants Adam Sandler just
finish his role in a new movie and now
he died are you doing there Adam
ooh nice twerking at him Adam wants to
check himself out to work he's like oh
yeah look at that oh yeah oh yeah damn
better what happened I've seen some
demons in my days but this this one
takes the prize oh he's fine he's fine
look at him he's doing it Jesus Christ
nice flip wrap Oh Oh what is he keep
losing your head add up [ __ ] the police
[ __ ] the police [ __ ] the police [ __ ] the
police
Adam what are you saying you can't say
that god damn it Adam how the [ __ ] are
you holding on to that Jesus Christ
mates Oh God see you later Adam it's
fine oh yeah Adam Sandler the best
Sandler in the world I take it all back
come on Adam honey elevate that
okay go at him that's right hotter Adam
is sick of all you and all your [ __ ] go
out I'm Chandler I'm Charlotte I'm
[ __ ] shot alert that's right [ __ ]
I'm Chandler ha ha ha
go Adam Sandler let him say there hasn't
you can wish she got from his me today
Adam said it really never cease car
right now now now now this is what I
call an Adam Sandler
hey you and you wanna go on a date I
don't understand like first time it
jumped so well of that never there it is
oh [ __ ]
hey kids are you doing Jesus Christ I
think that was an Adam Sandler I'm
[ __ ] sad no [ __ ] man
no Darius Oh such a shame
all right breasts we're gonna have to
episode if you enjoy watching smash that
like button on Adam Sanders tits and I
will see you in the next one thanks for
watching as always going to his next